I am in the national advanced driving
simulator at the University of Iowa it's
used to test drivers reactions in a
controlled repeatable environment and
also to test things that will be unsafe
in the real world
Tom's currently in the simulator
undergoing a study to look at driver
response to unintended acceleration the
vehicles going to accelerate quickly
without any input from Tom as if it were
malfunctioning Tom's gonna have to
identify that this event is going on and
press the brake very quickly to bring
the car under control but there's a
question I want to answer here recently
I did a video while driving it was on a
dead straight road with very little
traffic and I always felt in control of
the vehicle but was I is it actually
dangerous to talk into a camera while
driving so I'm going to spend 15 minutes
in this simulator distracted trying to
give this monologue to that camera and
I'm also going to spend 15 minutes in
here not distracted just driving and put
on a full attention on the road and the
team here are gonna analyze my results
and tell me how I've done and given I
was just doing 3525 probably not that
great the national advanced driving
simulator was built to recreate the most
realistic driving experience possible
anywhere it has a real vehicle cabinet
we can swap different vehicle cabs in
and out the motion base can travel 64
feet in the X and y directions and these
are basically steel belts that are
connected to large drives on either end
and then the hexapod portion of the
simulator is hydraulic that allows us to
experience roll pitch and yaw we also
have a turntable that can turn 330
degrees in either direction overall it
has 13 independent degrees of freedom we
have absolute control over what time of
day it is we have control over the
weather and traffic and yes the graphics
might not be up to modern video game
standards but after a few minutes in
here with all the motion you bring just
accepts that you're driving very broadly
we are interests
studying the relation between the driver
and the vehicle to improve safety so
that encompasses things like driver
impairment driver drowsiness extraction
or intoxication so we bring drivers in
actually give them a large dose of
alcohol get them in the simulator and we
can see how they perform we've also
compared that to things like cannabis so
some of the first studies with cannabis
and driving had been done in the
simulator here as well as Tom's driving
in the simulator talking to the video
camera I would expect to see him missing
certain information in the driving scene
generally if we find that interactions
that take the driver's eyes off the road
tend to be the worst but even in
situations where the driver is looking
straight ahead if their attentions
pulled to another task like talking to a
video camera that can often increase
distraction iemon caused the driver to
miss certain things if the driver
crashes they essentially move through
the vehicle or the pedestrian that they
collided with so we don't simulate the
dynamics of a crash but we are recording
that they crash we know the velocity of
that crash we know how severe that crash
would have been about as well as we
would have predicted so let me pull up
an example here my vehicle is gonna
drive through an intersection you
actually have the red stop sign
completely missed it whoa just did not
see that the thing is I'm actually
looking at the road that yes actually
but I'm not thinking about the road
because I'm too busy thinking about what
my next line is exactly we would call
this inattentional blindness and this is
when your attention is off the road even
though your eyes are there you're
missing information that's out in the
environment so we saw quite a bit of
swerving at the beginning of you drive
you had some trouble controlling your
speed you were going about 35 through a
25 school zone textbook case of
distracted driving
so I basically shouldn't film more
generally speaking yes thank you so much
thank you thank you so much to everyone
at the national advanced driving
simulator at the University of Iowa pull
down the description or click the link
on-screen for more about them all the
pedestrians here just just suicidal oh
this is not a stop sign I can just take
this well now I can't you're coming in
from the right
probably shouldn't check my phone while
I'm driving
[Music]